[Music]
one of the reasons this is so surreal is
because uh you're such an inspiration to
me that's real I think you're a genuine
artist a true artist everyone in the
scene knows that you're doing work that
is unparalleled and your podcast is of
course was a huge inspiration to me
because that that's what got me to start
my podcast yeah and I I I appreciate
that and that's very nicely to say of
course why'd you steal my
podcast no I I you know I know like I
know we joke about that but you know
certainly I didn't invent interviewing
but I did have a certain format and
style that you took
um and
I oh you're like really laughing a
little there it is yeah no no that's not
the fake
one you doing that on the show at all do
we have a
clip I well that's my one of my favorite
mirring quotes is I told you you that uh
I'm not a crier yeah and that even after
my divorce my wife leaves me I didn't
even cry and you said you're always
crying
Pete there's this thing where we we're
recording ourselves and trying to make
things last forever but also embracing
the fact that everything's just
dissolving in front of us you know
second time you use dissolve in a
different way which I appreciate so
you're saying that I'm a dissolver of
the old form yet everything we do just
dissolves I should mention that one of
the show's sponsors is lising breath
stps this green breath dissolving on
your too do you want something that
tastes that would be so old school and
clever I'd have to be impressed with
you I would not want to do that yeah you
just hold them up oh God or a girl on
roller skates goes by sure you can go
that way I miss those days do you the
girls on roller skates days when were
those days for
you seriously when were
they I I I never I never got
them I just just all I want is to call a
girl abroad and have it not be a
problem you can do that you can do that
and have it not be a problem of course
Pro broad girls you can get a pro that
you can call a
broad oh so just to be clear you're not
happy with Mark coming on and endorsing
prostitution to the god think this is a
Christian
[Laughter]
show